there are some people in the center that
might say you know what government
doesn't do all that well all that
government doesn't do all that much all
that well and this idea of massive
programs run by the federal government
is concerning
you know
it's funny that republicans like to
bring this up as boilerplate platitudes
but when you actually look at the
provisions in this bill two-thirds of
all americans support it and that
includes net 78 of republicans and net
25 percent of independents so those very
people that you were talking about so
you know it's easy to just
cast all this off as socialism and
communism and big government spending
but we are actually talking about
specific provisions that people want
that are popular expanding medicaid to
cover important provisions like uh
vision dental and and hearing uh
universal pre-k everything that i named
before they are all popular provisions
when we actually get into the nuts and
bolts of it
brian if this is so popular then why is
joe biden's approval rating in the 30s
according to even left-wing polls he's
losing on every single issue including
on kovid which by the way was the only
issue that he was in the positive on if
his agenda is so popular then how come
that's not reflected in his poll numbers
michael could a reason that his approval
ratings are low right now is because he
hasn't passed the agenda yet and if he
actually was able to pass the agenda the
numbers might go up higher
joe joe biden has been campaigning on
this from from day one and furthermore
he is the executive of the country right
now so while he hasn't passed this three
and a half trillion dollar really more
like five and a half trillion dollar law
he is executing on his agenda right now
on the border on the economy just just
today he was bragging about how many
people are are losing their jobs and
there are mass firings but that's
actually good because of public health
or something like that and so i think
people are seeing what the agenda is i
don't think what he's passing in this
law is radically different from the way
he's governing and it's simply not
popular brian last word to you here's
the thing
i i think the difference between at
least what i do and what the right wing
media ecosystem does is i treat my
audience like they're intelligent
because i know that it's not just a
matter of joe biden trying to pass these
things but him deciding i'm not going to
that we have a 50 50 majority in the
senate with a filibuster that requires a
60 vote threshold to pass any
legislation so let's not pretend that
joe biden
is choosing will ryan
i know your audience is very intelligent
so i hope they've heard of budget
reconciliation you are aware that the
democrats can get through their agenda
with 50 votes plus one in many cases
they're negotiating and they're not
choosing not to do that because they
want republicans they're negotiating to
own some of their agenda
and they're negotiating that right now
and and something will pass and by the
way just one more fact you know you
you've called this a 3.5 trillion dollar
package it's funny how i called it the
republican priorities
it's funny for for republican priorities
everything is in one year increments but
for democratic priorities everything is
the number over 10 years the fact is
this is a 350 billion dollar package
over the course of one year that is half
the cost of our annual military budget
and no one asks how we pay for it when
we pump 700 billion dollars into the
military for contractors and god knows
what so we can enjoy perpetual wars but
god forbid a senior right here at home
gets a hearing aid
brian donald donald trump the last
republican president ran on bringing the
troops home and he did draw down the
troops all over there in fact the last
president to push for these perpetual
wars in all of these countries was the
democrat barack obama and and
furthermore in this budget one of the
one of the stranger items in there is a
provision called tree equity and it's a
program to spend a lot of money planting
trees in poor neighborhoods i actually
have no problem with it i think that of
all the terrible programs here tree
equity is perfectly fine i like
beautiful neighborhoods but but if
you're really comparing the urgency of
tree equity versus the national security
of the united states i think the
priorities might be a little bit jumbled